ah captain you're at my desk just what I
want to see first thing in the morning
you're three minutes late Peralta not my
fault
I had a plumbing problem which reminds
me I'm gonna need a new departmentally
issued phone come on really I'm a few
minutes late you're gonna call me out in
front of everyone good idea
everyone gather round so I can call out
Peralta in front of you okay fine I was
three minutes late I'm sorry for doing
one thing wrong oh it's more than one
thing let's start with the Christophe
murder
there's an amazing solve I got him to
confess in 20 minutes you also
mislabeled the evidence so that
confession is worthless if the sergeant
hadn't caught your mistake here are
three cases with sloppy paperwork here
are two pictures one is your locker the
other is a garbage dump in the
Philippines can you tell which is which
that one's to them they're both your
locker I should've guessed guys it's
good this folder is labeled undies comma
dirty so I won't confuse it with undies
comma clean also who cares about all
these rules I have more felony arrests
than any other detective here you also
have more mice living in your desk than
any other detective Algernon
you guys Algernon's back get rid of the
mouse and get your act together now he's
crappy
hello it's with the cast I sprained my
wrist oh no what happened don't worry
about it I'm fine yeah geez Amy back off
leave the guy alone all right huddle up
everybody bring it in bring it so he
wouldn't say what happened which can
only mean one thing he's in a Fight Club
no he did it doing something he's
embarrassed by like smiling only
question is how do you hurt your arm
smiling could be a sports injury I
sprained my wrist in college playing
field hockey men's field hockey yeah
it's much more violent than the women's
game we're not allowed to wear anything
that protects our breasts attention
everyone I can hear you speculating
about the nature and origin of my injury
from my office I tripped over an uneven
sidewalk I did not think it was relevant
to your jobs the jobs which you should
all be doing right now get to work do
you want to know how I actually hurt my
wrist yes I was looking Kevin and I
attend a class for fitness and for fun
oh my god I've mastered all the moves
the pizza toss the tornado the Scorpion
the oopsie doodle why are you telling me
this because no one will ever believe
you know
sick son of a [ __ ] for you and you and
you what are these these madam are STDs
what are you talking about buddy
STDs save the dates for Vivian on my
wedding
ah yes hey just out of curiosity how
many people have you given STDs to lots
like a hundred what's going on oh okay I
get it
STD has another meaning you're gross no
one else is gonna think that everyone is
going to think that but it's sweet that
your mind didn't go there thank you
it is kind of sweet well your first
dance be to you give me fever will you
be serving crabs as the reception the
other Arby's guys this is my wedding
this is important to me no more jokes
you're right and we're sorry yeah we
love you buddy works and all sorry I
made a rash decision I was itching to
say it okay I'm done I have an STD so
just RSVP here yeah the numbers right on
their shoes great so again your alibi is
a mysterious stranger handed you the gun
made you put your prints on it robbed
the store and then hid the gun in your
underpants well yeah if you say it like
that it don't sound believable oh hey
captain did you get my report on the
Finley murder oh yeah looks it over nice
work
good thanks dad why is everyone staring
at me you just called captain holt dad
he said thanks dad what
no I didn't I said thanks man do you see
me as a father figure Peralta no if
anything I see you as a father figure
cuz you're always bothering me hey show
your father some respect I didn't call
him dad no no no Jacob I take it as a
compliment
it's not a big deal I called Vivian mom
once and she's my fiancee guys jump on
that Boyle has psychosexual issues old
news but you calling hope daddy daddy is
not on the table here but you did call
him dad dude you shut up you've done
nothing but lie since you got here
alright alright I was lying about the
whole dump but the dad thing that happy
he admitted that his alibi was a lie it
was a trap all part of my crazy
devious plan I believe you thank you son
you want to talk about it later over a
game of catch I'd like that hey you guys
see the dude I brought him today the
drug dealer 81 years old I think it's
the oldest collar of my entire career I
went to arrested a 96 year old for
flashing I was terrified he died in my
backseat or flashed me my oldest collar
was 78 but the PCP Manor fight like she
was 20 what about 250 year old twins
does that count as 100 year old no good
no you're talking oldest bags
68 that's not that old yeah but I was
only 20 it's wonder you were even a cop
then no man it's before I got into the
Academy Charles isn't talking about his
oldest arrest
yeah well that's arrest 68 like I said
God you had sex with a 68 year old when
you were in your 20s you know how it is
you can you have a chance to bed an
older woman you ever no that is not an
older woman that's an old woman that's
someone's grandma she was actually
that's how I met her
sockets you a replacement hip with some
serious torque having sex with a
transformer that is no one's
oh hello yes guys guys so check it out
Hitchcock who fell asleep in the break
room so I put his hand in a bowl of warm
water come on man that's the stupidest
prank ever
ah no it's the smartest because it
involves biology I bet it worked already
let's go Jack
Hitchcock no he's drowning he's drowning
save a man
take it back Jake great prank
hey there Boyle how was your weekend
well actually I got a little sick oh
really
sorry to hear that man yeah bullets over
Broadway was on TV I came down with a
big old Dianne Wiest infection
like artists Kelly how was your weekend
that's fun Kelly and I hit the park went
for a long walk
fell asleep watching TV Wow sounds like
a fun weekend with Kelly
so Kelly is that Scully's wife or his
dog wait no one knows Scully's wife's
name I think Kelly's his dog went for a
long walk that's what you do with a dog
you know what a long walk with a person
at sunset talking about nothing and
everything sounds awful hit the park
that's a dog my wife takes the babies to
the park all the time all right we're
doing this let's play wife or dog Hey so
Scully what do you do at the park with
Kelly
oh we just walk around she gets antsy if
she doesn't get outside enough and then
it's just yeah yeah all day long hey
what's going on
peanut butter she'll eat it right out of
the jar how old is coming again well
she's getting up there but if she's
pretty spry for age especially
considering she got hit by that car year
ago oh that's so awful was she chasing
something into the street or yeah just
getting me the newspaper all right this
is useless Scully is Kelly your wife or
your dog how can you ask me that I still
don't know which it is could be either I
could not tell you I can't believe that
waxing the floor that we're all stuck in
here I've never seen them do this before
if you do it once a month we just never
been on the night shift I know it's like
we're being punished we are for going to
Florida ah I don't listen to so much
stuff you all say well frankly I pity
the lot of you you look out there and
see a problem I look out there and see
an opportunity I'm gonna slide on that
slippery floor all the way from Holt's
office to the elevator you're gonna do
the fbp that's right Rosa I'm doing the
bull bullpen
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you